the philosopher Tolstoy wrote about how
in order to live man must find a way to
connect the final two to the infinite we
need to form some kind of kinship
between ourselves and the unfathomable
vastness of the cosmos we are star stuff
said Carl Sagan we are made of atoms
literally cooked in the furnaces of
dying stars and so in many ways we are
infinite yet as psychologists Ernest
Becker wrote we are nevertheless housed
in heart pumping breath gasping decaying
bodies simultaneously gods and so we
need a bridge a conduit to the numinous
and perhaps no greater instrument in the
history of humankind then the telescope
can provide this cathartic bridge as it
blasts open new tunnels between the mind
and the other Ross Anderson's dazzling
essay on the James Webb telescope
reminds us that in his metaphysics
Aristotle called C the noblest faculty
Anderson goes on to describe with
requisite virtuosity how the Deep Field
images of the universe taken by the
Hubble literally mainly all of space and
time so that the Space Telescope has
downloaded space and time into our
eyeball whereas once we were blind
how we could see he continues through
the sheer aesthetic force of its
discoveries the Hubble has distilled the
complex abstractions of astrophysics
into singular expressions of color
vindicating keith's is coupling beauty
is truth truth
and thus allowing the layman to witness
the scope and grandeur of the universe
through an unprecedented expansion
something the new James Webb Space
Telescope will take to a whole Anderson
continues the telescope has provided
nothing less than an ontological
awakening a forceful reckoning with what
is as we get to witness galaxy pinwheel
indeed something happens to us during
these moments of introspective
contemplation drunk on all as we
literally get to contemplate space and
time on a scale just shy of the infinite
enlarges the boundaries of our being
astronauts have called this the overview
Neil deGrasse Tyson calls it the cosmic
perspective we get to move beyond the
self toward something grander more
majestic ineffable we chase these
experiences ravenous as Henry wise Meyer
right as spirituality waves experience
is the new faith we are refugees
and so we shall continue achingly to
resuscitate that sense of humbling and
comprehension so that we may say I yes I
remember what I forgot in the words of
mezack r dot the other world is this
world right we see
you